un député de la province de l'ontario
mauril bélanger avait milité pour la
modification de l'hymne national pendant
plusieurs années mais un sentiment
d'urgence s'était installé en 2015
lorsqu'il avait reçu un diagnostic de
sclérose latérale amyotrophique encore
la maladie de lou gehrig
peu après les élections fédérales
canadiennes de 2015 la chambre des
communes du canada a donc adopté le
projet de loi en juin 2016
en présence de l'ex député bélanger ce
dernier est décédé quelques mois puis
vers de montréal bélanger pour rendre la
version anglaise de l'hymne national
canadien neutre de jean a été adopté en
troisième lecture unis environ une
quarantaine de minutes regardez bien les
images sur l'écran on peut voir monsieur
bélanger tenait absolument à être
présents et la bonne nouvelle c'est que
225 députés ont voté en faveur de la
modification 74 contre le projet de loi
prévoit le remplacement dans la version
anglaise
il faudra que le sénat adopte le projet
mais en raison de l'opposition du parti
conservateur
le projet de loi est restée bloquée au
sénat et ce pendant plus de 18 mois les
amendements et les sous-amendement
provenance des banquettes des
conservateurs s'accumulaient dans le
débat sur ce projet doit ses 210 à la
chambre haute
l'une des sénatrices qui menait la ronde
était la conservatrice line beac aussi
farouchement opposé au projet de loi il
y avait le sénateur conservateur devil
wears qui disait avoir reçu des
centaines de courriels et de lettres de
canadiens qui voulait garder line tel
qu'il était de dire le sénateur
conservateur
le projet de loi est de rendre les
politiquement correct mais je crois
qu'il l'est déjà
puis il ajoutait les canadiens sont
fiers de leur hymne
ilm implore de faire ce qui est en mon
pouvoir pour le garder en état tous ces
sénateurs aurait rimé que les canadiens
puissent s'exprimer son sujet par le
biais de consultations publiques ou
encore d'un sondage national voie
référendaire
mais cela ne s'est pas produit pourtant
un débat a pu prendre forme sur l'espace
public la question
angers est dans un état de santé plutôt
critique et qu'ils vont mourir
incessamment est ce que vous le faites
pas sympathie pour mauril bélanger ou
par conviction quand ils arrivent avec
cet état de santé très précaire
j'ai tiré il en profite pour poser un
geste d'ouverture envers les autres dans
l'hymne national avec un seul mot et non
pas qu'ils l'utilisent mais y pose un
geste qui l'honore
du fait aussi qu'il est dans une
situation précaire mais sa marque sont
eux aussi je me dis que les paroles des
données nationale d'un texte officiel
qui a été mis ce qui a été publié il ya
55 ans soit 15 ans eh ben ça évolue
aussi la société en bien et on doit
faire des efforts et enfin pour faire un
seul que maintenant on reconnaisse que
la société est inclusive c'est le nous
au lieu de deux la tradition sont
difficiles
[Musique]
romain c'est uma
au final les canadiens et canadiennes se
dote d'un hymne national plus inclusif
qui pourra inspirer d'autres nations sur
l'égalité des sexes un reportage de
radio canada international
[Musique]